Greg thanks for joining us on short
notice how are you I'm well dan good to
be with you thanks for the invitation
well I've been talking about this the
last two days now on the show of is
there a way to extrapolate and maybe we
make it a a team play off and then how
do we get through all of the hurdles
here what do you think of the
possibility of of that happening where
we go from four to eight and how could
you see that actually working it is the
most frequently asked question of me
during my now four football seasons as a
conference commissioner so understand
that topic in my view will never go away
it has not been the subject of planning
strategizing here's where we go
among the commissioners who lead I'll
just go back in my history I was
commissioner at the one double-a level
and you saw migration steadily for four
to eight to 16 to 24 so I think there
will always be pressure on increasing
the number but there has to be a balance
of that conversation right now the
feeling is we've struck that balance
with the knowledge that there's always
going to be tension around who is in and
who is left out but if I had a team
let's say and all five of the power
conferences are represented and then I
had three at large after that I don't
want to add more games and I don't know
if we can get around the conference
championship game or if you if you have
that I just think this weekend would be
unbelievable if you started the playoffs
this weekend and you had right eight
versus one yeah Notre Dame against Ohio
State like I think college football's
missing out on storylines Greg yeah you
know I just do we have marvelous
storylines in fact some of the
storylines I wish I could just not pay
attention to that let's just go back
substantively okay from the Southeastern
Conference perspective we were the first
to have a conference championship game
ours is one versus four that's not an
infrequent high-level game for us
we think it's special and it becomes the
issue of what is the gift what where do
you where do you give where do you yield
and I was not in the Commissioner share
when the college football playoff was
created but the reality that we have to
acknowledge is many of my universities
go right into final exams next week we
still have a bowl system that from our
perspective works it's evolving we work
to conclude things prior to the start of
the spring semester so that Monday
championship game date is intentional we
also have dynamics with holidays and NFL
games and could something someday fit
sure but the discussion of what's the
give what what do we give up do we give
up a regular-season games will
accommodate four more teams that seems
unwise for what college football means
to our campuses and our communities and
frankly to the participants because our
student-athletes were clearly rather
play 12 and 11 we went to the standard
C's and so it is it is there's more
complexity there are more pieces to that
conversation than maybe a parent would
just go to eight and I'll tell you if
you ever went to eight the next question
is when you're gonna go I know that
every every bracket exists that's why
we're in a start-up of four that's
worked pretty well but Commissioner it
feels like money Trump's everything here
whether we admit to it or not you know
the bottom line and you know everybody
it feels like that we're increasing they
be a number of teams that can make the
playoffs or do make the playoffs where
is college football what do you have
three percent of the teams they're gonna
make a playoff the NFL has thirty seven
percent of those teams making the
playoffs and I know you're gonna say
well we have bowl games okay those are
nice but these these other you know
leagues these other sports you actually
get a chance to play for a championship
you only have four schools to get a
chance to play yeah that puts great rate
on the regular season so I won't say we
just have all games how about that deal
I will say that some of those NFL teams
run into the playoffs with what nine and
seven records eight and eight records
yeah when you walk through my
all season this year the SEC for the
first time in college football playoff
history as a conference with eight teams
in the top 25 there's a rigor in our
schedule there's an intensity around our
competition that sometimes boils over
but I think that provides those
storylines and in great great meaning
even into early November where people
still have opportunities perhaps to move
up you know one of the oddities that
we're dealing with in fact I was fully
prepared for this question so I'll just
tea it up as you see just repeats you
know Alabama's been in this position
each year the playoff Clemson's moved
into that position and does that cause
people does that circumstance cause
people to view things differently that's
one of those again rhetorical questions
I ask myself but we ought to think about
something like that
but if I said if I showed you data where
the fans wanted this let's say 80% of
the fans say let's have a team play does
that matter at all to use the
Commissioner well I think about that but
that's not the only deciding factors
earlier it was it was about the money
all it was about the money just maybe
expand and figure out how much money is
there it's it is though about college
football being special we've got we have
a unique approach I think these
conference championship games provide
storylines even if it's not a
one-in-four matchup
you know Texas and Oklahoma playing you
have northwestern playing for a Big Ten
championship game and the the amount of
attention on college football this
weekend is increased because of
conference championship games your
follow up will be but would need even be
greater well now you say let's get a
ques two five conference champions when
we were creating things we had some
teams and some of those are that way
this year that might you know some teams
in conference championship games aren't
ranked up just yeah there are we gonna
put it on ranked team that happens to
win a conference championship game
automatically into the playoffs
that's a very different approach than we
have with the four best teams as
established right now well it took a
long time for me to convince all of
these coaches that you know the BCS is
nice but if you go to four teams
it could be nicer so you know that I
mean Notre Dame would be out they'd be
undefeated and they would be out like
like Auburn was you know a decade and a
half ago right you know so we got to for
when nobody wanted to go to four and I
remember all of these coaches I'd talked
to and say you know let's change the BCS
now it'd be Clemson in Alabama but
there'd be no drama to the college
football season like I want to I want to
add a little bit more drama to this
maybe it ends up Clemson and Alabama but
if I you can own December I believe and
that may be true I would counter though
there's an incredible level of drama
around college football now and and you
can imagine I live in my own world or
maybe outside the eleven states of the
SEC the dramas at a different level and
I say that with a smile and great
affection for the intensity what might
change I don't I don't think we've ever
seen circumstances where a boom you just
change a bracket and there's no other
dominoes that follow and so we go back
to principles I talked about that
whether one wants to be cynical or not
we're important we honor the ability for
conferences to schedule differently so
that's a point of controversy now we
want the playoff completed before the
spring academic semester starts we honor
the conference championship games we do
provide a break in December and a piece
of that is intentional because we do
have young men who are graduating and we
have young men who have final exams to
take I also from my my past life watched
both the physical and the personnel poll
on just adding games and that goes back
to watching a 16 in playoff format and I
I am sensitive magnifying
that dynamic because the physical
intensity around Southeastern Conference
football is is significant and adding to
that in December as long we ought to
think about carefully before just yeah I
I'm with you on that I don't want to be
adding games but you know like if you
can have nine conference games for
everybody I mean there was a point
though Greg when you didn't have all the
conference's have a conference title
game like it it's constantly moving it
feels like and I think in five years
from now if we have a conversation I
think we're having a different
conversation but I do understand a lot
of the things that you're pointing out I
just think if you look at the
hypothetical to it I think the
possibilities are a lot of fun I don't
want to get to 16
I don't want to go there I don't want to
get to 12 but I do want to give like
Central Florida deserve to least be in
the conversation last year I thought
that they were a very good team and
maybe this year as well but to have that
possibility that's what you want in all
sports is the possibility that's why we
love March Madness and you don't have
that with college football that's what I
would like to see eight teams maybe you
get an at-large we're a Boise State
years ago or Central Florida you know
that's that's what I would like to have
I'd like to have a little bit more of
that and have these storylines and maybe
it comes down to Alabama and Clemson for
the national title and it probably will
and the good news is there are
thoughtful people involved in the
conversation and you you kind of put a
milestone out there which was Auburn's
undefeated season and I'm not looking at
the calendar I think it 2004 or you know
there was another ten years before there
was the kind of change that were proof
was pursued in the aftermath of that
circumstance so in real time it seems
the pace of consideration may be slow
there are reasons and I think still good
reasons to remain at four but you know
the future is the future and right now I
was pleased to see two SEC teams ranked
in those top four if Nick Saban calls
you right now is it a good thing or a
bad thing
that's why I talked to him with with
some regularity not frequency and those
are always pretty straightforward
conversations whether I'm delivering a
message sure he is and with all my
coaches I talked at 3:00 yesterday have
that positive relationships and
conversations always good if you could
go to one sec tailgate and you got to be
honest Greg yeah I would be an old
Oxford no that's the right answer now if
you if you ask me like we're game venue
in Baton Rouge the Alabama LSU game this
year was incredible well the atmosphere
was the game wasn't your football
tactician it's fascinating
Ole Miss by the way never loses a
tailgate that's the one thing that they
go undefeated in we've got a lot of
special places so before I get myself in
too much trouble a 14 favorite tailgate
now of course you do thanks for joining
us Greg we appreciate your time and have
fun this weekend I appreciate the
invitation would be a great day on
Saturday that's Greg Sankey SEC
Commissioner for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]